الرصاصه والاعتقال لا يميز بين الطفل
وغيره هكذا يكون الفلسطينيون وهم يشاهدون
ما يتعرض له اطفالهم على يد الجيش
الاسرائيلي اثناء قمعه لتظاهرات
الفلسطينيات او عندما يقتحم المدن والقرى
والمخيمات في الضفه الغربيه 45 طفلا قضوا
هذه السنه من مجموعه
فلسطينيين قتلوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
حسب احصائيات وزاره الصحه في مشهد يعكس
سياسه اسرائيل تجاه اطفال فلسطين
على هذه الافاعي هل هي شكلت ضوء اخطار
لجنود الاسرائيليين لاطلاق النار هدف
القتل تجاه الاطفال الفلسطينيين
الاعتقال الاسرائيليه لا تستثني الاطفال
فهناك 100 و60 طفلا يقبعون في السجون
الاسرائيليه من بين اربعه الاف و 700 اسير
على الرغم من ان هذا العدد لا يعكس حقيقه
عمليه للاطفال حتى اكتوبر من هذا العام
كان عدد المعتقلين من الاطفال خلال العام
2022 750 همم طفل وهناك حالات لا تثق يعني
يلقى القبض عليه هو اطلاق سراحه بكفاله
يعني مباشره يعني بعد ساعات وتكون
المؤسسات الراعيه لشؤون الاطفال والاسرى
ان اسرائيل اعتقلت منذ العام 67 وحتى
بدايه الشهر الجاري نحو 50 الف طفل بهدف
التاثير النفسي على الاطفال وذويهم على حد
سواء